[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us
one thing uniting many parts of the
country during the pandemic is the need
for more protective equipment for health
care workers
this got the attention of a little boy
with a town for art
who decided to try his hand at helping
out
our dr taran arula has his story
this is my auntie allison i made this
picture because she's a
doctor at cornell when the pandemic hit
eight-year-old ethan goldsmith overheard
his parents talking about his aunt
she was fighting the virus on the front
lines she's a cancer doctor
so she needs ppe yeah you can see
he has ppe on right now
last year few people could tell you what
ppe stood for
now it's as basic as abc's
personal protective equipment it's like
masks or gloves or what doctors
use to help patients dpe
is very important to like not get
yourself
sick and protect yourself and do we have
enough ppe
in this country um there's still places
where they don't have ppe so
we're trying to donate money to get ppe
that's when ethan decided to do whatever
he could to help his healthcare heroes
by picking up his pencils
and markers so this guy is named dr fox
and it says dr fox has the biggest heart
months into the quarantine and dozens of
requests later
ethan has raised hundreds for the
organization get us ppe
who work to supply personal protective
equipment to frontline workers
nationwide
so here's his drawing of me
my kids got a kick out of it um my hair
is certainly curly
dr megan ranny an emergency physician at
brown university co-founded get us ppe
to actively respond to the shortages
around the country
many people think that this was a
problem early on in the pandemic
and that now we have enough there are
absolutely still shortages
this problem is here and it's actually
getting worse again
as we head into the fall what started as
a tweet to raise awareness
grew into a grassroots movement we've
donated well over two and a half million
pieces of personal protective equipment
across the country
even small amounts make a difference and
whether it's drawing a picture or
donating some ppe
those little things add up and you know
drop by drop we make an ocean and that's
true in this time as much as in
any other i mean a drawing for you it's
beautiful
thank you you're welcome
[Music]
oh i want mine he does he has a
wonderful story isn't it no
eva's a good artist i like his legs i
like his rhymes dr fox has the biggest
heart fixing hearts
is his art fabulous you go ethan
goldsmith thank you
thanks also to his auntie allison who's
there on the front lines